j'aimerais qu'on montre un autre extrait
elle est allée à la rencontre de
monsieur gonzalez c'est un secrétaire
général d'une grande marque de luxe qui
refusait de parler ils ont réussi à se
pointer devant chez lui comme vous
l'avez dit mais ils n'ont pas vraiment
été bien reçu est ce que vous trouvez ça
normal
mais gilles arrêté survient chez vous
vous êtes tranquillement
on commence à voir les affaires vont
très bien très bien
vous avez de l'activité en ce moment
tout était niée ça l'accueil est
tellement chaleureux au moins qu'on en
profite pour parler de faux des doigts
et passe de personnes m'ont parlé du
fait qu'elle avait eu des problèmes avec
vous c'est vrai ou pas soit on va te
faire voir des gages et doucement
doucement sont pas venir sur son lieu il
deviendra mais alors rien dit alors vous
avez vu nos idées des images voilà très
très fort très dur gilles verdez je suis
en total désaccord avec vous cyril si
vous ne retenez vous ferez pas
l'émission
alors si vous voulez obtenir des
informations que quelqu'un vous en
empêche physiquement comme la vo menace
vous faire en sa porte au nez
le journalisme excusez moi vous
christine kelly la journaliste assises
étaient bout le journaliste de boîte de
nuit là le journalisme
excusez moi et moi de vous dire ça j'ai
fait des bouts d'antaloor non non je
vous le dirai quand il y en a tout plein
ya un truc très grave c'est que la
productrice qui travaillent sur
l'émission depuis des années me dit
jean-michel n'est pas journée ici si le
journaliste ali les reporters de guerre